bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors on vient
d'évoquer voilà c'est relations
tumultueuses entre ankara et paris quel
est l'objectif aujourd'hui de la visite
du chef de la diplomatie turque
une manière de renouer le dialogue avec
avec la france mais à écouter dans ses
relations franco-turques il ya toujours
une alternance du chaud et du froid
comme oudi la turquie je pense qu'un
pays qui est un un habile joueur
d'échecs et en fait on voit toujours que
les limites qui est laquelle on parvient
c'est à dire on a toujours l'impression
on va être proche de la rupture
et puis au dernier moment et bien
effectivement il ya une dynamique tôt
pour aller dans le sens d'une
réconciliation
faut pas croire qu'il y aura d'un seul
coup des relations normalisées sont très
bonne entre les deux pays comme elle
avait pu être savez peut être le
carrière est une vingtaine d'années au
moment où la turquie avait encore
l'espoir dante intégré dans l'union
européenne
incontestablement les tensions se sont
accrues ces dernières années et en
particulier depuis que emmanuel macron
et et différentes raisons mais donc
voilà l'idée s'est montré que l'on veut
pas rompre mais ça c'est l'idée de la
visite mais dans le même temps les
désaccords subsistaient alors depuis le
début de l'année on voit que ankara
multipliant les gestes envers ces années
occidentaux et régionaux justement à
l'image de cette vie du chef de la
diplomatie
à paris on sait qu'il ya également le
sommet de l'otan le 14 juin prochain
est-ce que voilà la turquie et dont la
tante de feu faut mais on sait qu'il y
aura aussi une rencontre avec joe biden
oui alors c'est important ce sommet
parce que c'est un des points forts de
la turquie la turquie
vous savez en pilier orientale comme on
dit de l'otan une organisation qu'on
avait annoncé état de mort cérébrale
comme l'avait dit mme à nous-mêmes trump
semblait dubitatif sur l'avenir de cette
alliance
et puis comme par hasard elle s'est
refait une santé si je puis dire sur la
question ukrainienne voir à nouveau on a
suspecté la russie de mauvaises
intentions et c'est là que erdogan a
très très bien joué puisque et bien il a
au contraire apporté son soutien à
l'ukraine s'est rapproché de l'ukraine
donc il apparaît plus que jamais comme
l'allié indispensable pour contrer les
visées des ennemis de l'otan donc a
désigné comme tel à savoir la russie au
premier chef donc s'il avait pas la
crise du crédit yen on pourrait se dire
à quoi sert encore le temps donc cette
cette crise a ressuscité d'une certaine
manière et la turquie a très bien joué
donc je pense qu'il atteint erdogan
attend très sereinement ce sommet ont
montré une fois de plus qu'il est un
allié indispensable donc erdogan joue
très bien parce que d'un côté
bon il n'a pas des mauvaises relations
avec la russie or on a vu qu'il y avait
des opérations parfois un sujet
énergétique ou la syrie mais dans le
même temps c'est un allié ou un
partenaire un dos ils ont en tout cas
difficile à gérer donc je pense qu'il va
marquer des points lors de ce sommet et
qu'abidal qui avait eu des mots très
durs va devoir probablement aller vers
plus de modération comme probablement
aussi plusieurs pays de l'alliance
atlantique dans la france pour revenir
justement
change entre entre la france et la
turquie c'est que le ministre turc des
affaires étrangères avant son arrivée a
publié une tribune dans le journal
l'opinion il a d'ailleurs déclaré que la
turquie et la france sont et resteront
deux pays alliés et amis
c'est un appel du pied diplomatique
justement à la proche de ce sommet oui
il veut effectivement aplanir les
différends en tout cas les atténuée
parce que ce sommet doit être une
réussite bien évidemment voix pour
erdogan parce que le contexte est
favorable mais encore une fois de toute
façon la turquie et de fête
allier puisqu'ils sont dans l'alliance
atlantique c'est le nom de l'otan
maintenant on peut être alliés mais on
peut être pas forcément amis donc je
pense que le terme d' amis il est pas
forcément le bon il ya encore une fois
certain nombre de sujets sur lesquels la
turquie finalement a besoin de la france
mais la france a aussi besoin de la
turquie
donc la turquie a besoin de la france
parce que c'est un un effectif en un
acteur important au niveau international
par sa présence au conseil de sécurité
de l'onu en tant que membres permanents
bottes eto'o mais aussi un acteur de
plus en plus important en méditerranée
orientale
on a vu qu'elle a soutenu activement la
grèce à laquelle elle a vendu d'ailleurs
des avions rafale mais la france a aussi
besoin de la turquie parce que elle et
pas seulement le pilier orientale de
l'otan mais elle est surtout le gardien
un peu des vagues migratoires donc on
sait que là dessus elle peut ouvrir
fermer les vannes certaine manière
donc c'est chacun finalement et contre 1
de collaborer avec l'autre et on aurait
pu rajouter les questions proprement
interne à la france sur la question de
l'islam
là aussi donc on sait que la turquie a
une certaine influence et ça peut être
un facteur important pour la france de
de disputer avec la turquie sur
l'influencé qu'elle peut avoir sur
l'islam de france l'islam européen d'une
manière générale quand elle la turquie
et bien elle se veut un peu le porte
étendard justement de de l'islam sunnite
au proche orient mais aussi dans les
communautés expatriées donc tout ceci
effectivement nécessite un dialogue
permanent mais aussi à une situation de
tension qui n'est pas finalement pour
déplaire forcément aux deux
protagonistes puisqu'un macron ça lui
permet de s'affirmer comme le rempart
face à une certaine une certaine forme
d'islam politique
et puis quand à erdogan est bien aussi
ça lui permet de s'affirmer comme je les
dis le gardien finalement de l'islam
sunnite qui serait outragé par les
caricatures de charlie hebdo ou par
d'autres phénomènes de crispation donc
voilà on a une attitude un peu ambiguë
finalement une coopération qui est
nécessaire et indispensable mais de
l'autre aussi des tensions qui ne sont
pas forcément pour déplaire à ces deux
acteurs merci beaucoup en tout cas
pierre berthelot d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé à l'ups et directeur
de la revue orient stratégique